oh no comment  nope he's a great dude he's a great dude  yeah yeah no I don't want to talk about  that Brittany Furlan blushing at the  Maxim Hot 100 party after photos of her  making out with rocker Tommy Lee  surfaced last week I just think that  there's a lot of not good guys in LA  there's just a lot of guys because  obviously look we're at the Maxim Hot  100 party there's a new hot babe like I  said every five minutes and dudes like  are not very you know they want a new  girl every five minutes you know so it's  very hard I think dating is very hard in  LA but it's like once you meet someone  really cool then you know it's that's  what it's about I mean I think that I've  kind of I don't know we just used up  date I think vibe with someone you vibe  with someone  [Music]  you